what's going on man you all right I uh I
had better days got blow it all over
yeah divorce is a tough subject to
breach for No One More Than This
Tennessee man who was attacked by his
wife and daughter after he made the big
announcement their weapons of choice a
knife and a frying pan so you said she
hit you with the frying pan did she hit
you with a knife
too you body camera recordings captured
the aftermath math of the attack on
January 27th in Ashland City Tennessee
chetam county sheriff's deputies
responded to the scene to find a man
covered in blood laying on his
neighbor's front
porch what's going on man you all right
I uh I had better days got blow all over
yeah right away the sheriff's deputy
asks about the weapon and the man says
it's a cross the way at his house the
scene of the crime where's the there
supposed to be a knife or something is
there a knife anywhere um that's that's
my house over there then the victim
explains what led up to the attack I I I
announced my wife I I want I want to
divorce and and and and 20 30 minuts ago
my wife and daughter a frying pan in in
a knife he says his wife choked him with
a belt and his daughter threatened to to
kill him as she held a knife he
eventually Broke Free and ran to his
neighbor's house for safety I got a
couple blows and I so she has a knife in
the frying pan No he sir across the
street yes sir okay next the sheriff's
deputy assures the man help is on the
way before assessing his injuries all
right hang tight I got EMS coming okay
huh uh yeah I'm trying to figure it out
you got where are you going hit at
cut you got a cut and you're
okay 9
28 how old are
you9
59 tell you man 59-year-old white male
bleeding profusely from the
head
hello have you been stabbed anywhere uh
no just just my head with the deputy
briefly speaks with the victim's
neighbor who was uninvolved in the
attack are you the who are you to I live
here okay she just a
neighbor over there soon the man again
rehashes what
happened I I told
my okay and you argu for several
hours
and I went bed
and 40 minutes ago I'm on my side and
I app pressure they'll be there shortly
my daughter come with the knife okay I
took the run
away trying to clean your are you are
you hurt anywhere else beside your head
no just my head just your head okay I
got you just relax man we'll take care
of
you you're bleeding but it's not like no
it's it's in your eye so it seems like
it's worse but it's actually not that
badal I'm going to put some pressure on
it so it we can stop the bleeding okay
the man tells First Responders he didn't
want to hurt his wife or daughter but
again confirms they came at him with a
knife and frying pan I got you you said
she hit you with a a knife and and a
frying pan there a large cast on I know
it hurts I know it hurts just just L fry
hand okay where and where's the knife um
I I rest a little way you wrestled
away away and I I shoved him down and
and ran out okay heard him I don't want
to hurt them I'm be larger than now so
you said she hit you with the frying pan
did she hit you with the knife too she
she she did she did okay and that was do
you know where yeah I think that was
here okay
she she hit you she she hit you with a
frying pan am a knife in the head yeah
and put a belt around my neck and pull
me down when my daughter going talk me
what's her name pam pam pam at this
point the deputy makes his way across
the street to the crime
[Music]
scene
[Applause]
[Music]
is
hello Sheriff's
Office let's pause this video really
quickly to give a shout out to Morgan
and Morgan for sponsoring today's law
and crime YouTube takeover and right
away I know what you're thinking you
don't want to see another ad what you
want from long crime is our crazy
content murders abductions DUIs
courtroom outbursts and the list goes on
on and on but with those incidents
sometimes they're pretty unexpected and
you could find yourself in a situation
like that if that's the case you know
right where to turn and it's Morgan and
Morgan America's largest injury Law Firm
here's the thing about Morgan and Morgan
they don't settle for lowball offers
here are some numbers recently in New
York a $6.8 million verdict in Florida
it was a $12 million verdict and in
Philadelphia $26 million all of these by
the way were significantly higher than
the highest insurance offer so here's
the best part about all of this there's
no fee unless you win so if you are
injured you can start by easily
submitting a claim at
www.for
the.com youout takeover or by dialing
law and that's 529 on your phone it's
only one click away on your smartphone
which I know you're probably using right
now okay let's get back to that video
body camera video captures the man's
daughter 29-year-old Kelly Davis covered
in blood and crying on the floor She
directs the deputy straight to her
mother 62-year-old Pam
Davis
okay
at 928 Central tell him man I got two
more victims in here lots of blood stand
by I'll try to get assess the
wounds she's a cancer
patient affirmative we got three victims
so far almost right away the deputy asks
about the knife okay where is there a
knife anywhere real quick I don't know
where it was down the hall okay as long
as I'm not going to get stabbed while
I'm trying to help you guys okay all
then he takes a look at Pam's injuries
are you you hurt anywhere besides just
right here yeah where are you hurt else
besides there my stomach in my back okay
is this just your arm ma'am right here
that and this and then when I went down
the stairs he threw me and then I hit
the okay uh the ammo bucket of stuff and
your head I twisted through here and
I've had had braak
surgery I know saying you're hurt and
it's chaotic just try to relax let me
try to get H first okay it's just the
open cut you have right here is this it
I have that one this one and then
somewhere up here I hit my head and it
cut okay how old are you I'm 62 the body
camera recording was taken at about 7:30
in the morning Kelly Davis says the
entire incident started the night before
at 11:00 p.m. it's to last night he he
came me
iation left you
out he started this at
11:00 last night the deputy then takes a
look at Kelly's injuries see you're
cut you're cut you got
[Applause]
stomach H it appears so slashed more
like not no no puncture looks like slash
marks how old are you ma'am I'm 30 on
February 19th of this
year 9 20th centur your third victim is
going to be 30-year-old female 160
lb0 got about seven or eight pretty
decent size slash wounds from a knife
bleeding after only about 3 minutes
inside the crime scene the deputy leaves
to get medical supplies all right hang t
let me see if I can get some go or
something
okay be back ma'am you okay I don't want
you passing out okay hang tired for me
okay I'm going to get some EMS over here
after checking out the wife and mother
the deputy heads over to emergency
responders to get supplies hey if we can
get someone over here too I got multiple
victims how many uh 64y old female deep
cuts and then I got a 30-year old female
there's two other victims two are in
there we need some Goss over over
here all three of them have deep Cuts
laceration the wife and the daughter in
there Cuts all over the place he's got
Cuts you got a medkit I got so I got a
little bit of Goss on
me
yeah I'm going to get that female on
there get some GS
yeah yeah I'm going to apply pressure
while we're
waiting we going to
have I think there's there two in there
and then one in here I think unless
there's
more that's where the body camera
recording ends but it's not the end of
the line for Kelly and Pam Davis they
both face attempted murder charges they
were booked into jail but have since
been released on bond reporting for long
crime I'm Sierra gaspie